mighty Marvel maybe dominating
pop-culture but not everyone is feeling
the love in a recent conversation with
Variety Jennifer Aniston star of the
beloved sitcom friends and the upcoming
Apple TV Plus series The Morning Show
lamented what she saw is a dearth of
cinematic choices due to the popularity
of comic book movies it was a rather
hard Segway in an interview which had up
until that point been focused on the
morning show and how it had been shaped
in part by the me2 movement Aniston was
asked a simple question about what
prompted her returned to television 15
years after shooting her last episode of
France and in her response she veered
quickly from marveling about all the
awesome choices available to viewers
since the advent of streaming - well not
marveling about Marvel she said and then
you're seeing what's available out there
and it's just diminishing and
diminishing in terms of its big Marvel
movies or things that I'm just not asked
to do I'm not really that interested in
living in front of a green screen
well we suppose it's kind of a bummer
when you're an actress who is well known
for starring on one of the most popular
sitcoms in the history of television and
then you find that your agent is always
trying to talk you into taking roles in
these silly comic-book pictures where
you'll be forced to report to work and
pretend to talk to a gun-toting CGI
raccoon all day the interviewer
responded to this unprompted disc by
noting how much Hollywood has changed in
recent years to which Aniston replied
it's changed so much I think we would so
love to have the era of meg Ryan come
back I just think it would be nice to go
into a movie theater sit cozy I think we
should have a resurgence let's get the
terms of endearment back out there you
know heaven can wait Young Frankenstein
Blazing Saddles could by girl it seems
to have become somewhat fashionable to
trash the Marvel Machine as of late
however so while it may seem a little
out of left field for Aniston to cite
Marvel movies as the reason why she's
choosing to continue working in
television she's certainly not alone
most recently martin scorsese made
headlines for blasting comic book movies
in general and in far more direct
fashion when asked if he had kept up
with the latest releases in the
superhero genre the filmmaker flatly
stated that's not cinema honestly the
closest I can think of them as well made
as they are with actors doing the best
they can under the circumstances is
theme parks it isn't the cinema of human
beings trying to convey emotional
psychological expiry
Frances to another human being cigar
says he isn't the only acclaimed
filmmaker to make the dubious comparison
between comic book films and theme parks
in a 2018 conversation with Radio Times
Magazine Jodie Foster unloaded on the
entirety of the superhero genre going so
far as to say that such films pollute
the cinematic landscape in much the same
way that poor environmental practices
pollute the planet Foster said going to
the movies has become like a theme park
studios making bad content in order to
appeal to the masses and shareholders is
like fracking you get the best return
right now but you wrecked the earth it's
ruining the viewing habits of the
American population and then ultimately
the rest of the world the comic book
movie backlash while nothing new does
appear to be picking up a little steam
perhaps it has something to do with the
fact that Avengers endgame recently
became the highest-grossing film of all
time or that the entire world briefly
lost their minds when Spiderman was
temporarily evicted from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe or that Joker has
become the most talked about film of the
fall we submit however that a sizable
market for non comic book fare still
exists and that if actors like Aniston
and filmmakers like Scorsese don't want
to work in the genre nobody's gonna
force them to heck we hear that Scorsese
just made his best film in years it's
called the Irishman and it's not even
about a guy flying around in a green
suit defeating his enemies by pelting
them with explosive shamrocks check out
one of our newest videos right here Plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]